BRITT: Patagonia I
had the fish fridge.
I'm gonna seal it off, kind
of like a grate, just to keep
anything from
getting down into it,
keep them from washing away.
Here, I have the
fish holding tank.
I'll probably eat one
tonight, and then I'll
save the rest for tomorrow.
But I have them in this little
tiny isolated wading pool.
Look at that one.
Nice, huh?
So they're just here
whenever I want them.
[music playing]
I hope the fish in my
holding tank are alive.
They should be.
They should be fine.
I'll take one out this
morning, probably,
cook up a fish for breakfast.
Get a little protein
to start my day.
I can't wait.
[music playing]
Oh [bleep].
[bleep] kidding me?
So I just got some really,
really disappointing news.
I came back to my wading
pool, and every fish is gone.
That was foolish of me.
Of course there's
predators in the area.
Of course they're
gonna find these fish
in this little shallow pond.
I probably had five
pounds of fish in here.
And I can see blood,
pieces of fish.
I mean, they were
just easy pickings.
That was dumb.
I just fed a whole
family of something.
Damn.
And it's too rocky
here to see any tracks.
My guess is that it's wolves.
Could have been anything.
[bleep]
It's beyond disappointing.
Oh well.
I guess that's a step
down from the fish fridge,
because I just
got totally taken.
In a survival situation, every
bit of protein that I can get
is vital.
Stupid, stupid, stupid.
Oh well.
It's in the past now.
What am I gonna
do about it, cry?
Right now, this is redemption.
So whether it be I'm starving
to death or I'm injured,
I'm not taking myself
out of this competition.
I'll get over it.
I'm over it right now.